if you're jumping into cana bridge of
spirits you may have noticed that the
game is more challenging than its cute
art style originally lets on to help out
we've got 13 tips and tricks to help you
be a better spirit guide
kana possesses an omnidirectional shield
that she can hold for a pretty long time
which in a pinch is a powerful defensive
measure but it's not one that you want
to rely on canis shield should be
considered a last resort something you
use when all else fails and you know
you're about to get hit this is because
the shield slows kana down
[Music]
early on this isn't too much of a
problem but after the opening hours of
the game you'll start facing groups of
enemies as well as more difficult mini
bosses and bosses all of which are both
fast and hit incredibly hard if your
shield takes too much damage it'll break
dealing you a big blow and sending you
flying so get into the habit of pairing
dodging and jumping to counter and avoid
enemy attacks parrying is an especially
crucial skill to get down and one that
can come in clutch later down the line
beyond defending kana can outright stop
certain attacks too kana's long-range
arsenal can knock enemies out of their
animations which will stop them from
using whatever attack they were
preparing using an arrow is the easiest
way to do so given the speed at which
kaina can fire one off however bombs can
typically work too
in bridge of spirits combat is hard and
the only way to really alleviate its
challenge is through kana's powerful rot
based abilities they are excellent for
dealing massive amounts of damage and
controlling the flow of battle to give
you some breathing room the only way to
use those abilities is by spending
courage which can most easily be
acquired in combat by dealing damage to
enemies spending courage is also the
only way you can heal during a fight too
so you need to be aggressive never back
off from a fight unless you absolutely
need to staying in the thick of combat
and weakening enemies is crucial for
building courage so you can both deal
the most damage and stay alive on
playstation 5 you can determine whether
you want to play bridge of spirits on
performance mode or fidelity mode the
former targets 60 fps at upscaled 4k
resolution while the latter locks the
frame rate at 30 fps at native 4k
resolution though fidelity mode makes
the game a whole lot prettier
performance mode is what you want it's
better from a combat perspective sure
the game won't be native 4k but you're
getting more frames per second and that
makes it a whole lot easier when you're
trying to time a parry or a dodge
kana has a just one more hit in your
finished state you can tell when you're
one hit away from death by looking at
the health bar it will be red and
flashing kana will always enter this
state before death so even if she only
has a tiny sliver of health left if it's
not red and blinking you have at least
one more hit before you're one hit away
from dying so to maximize the effects of
health items it's better to wait until
you've entered this state before healing
you can usually only heal a few times
each fight so just healing whenever is
not an ideal strategy wait until you
need to heal before deciding to heal
on playstation 5 the dual sense
controller will vibrate with a soft
heartbeat like frequency when you're
close to a hidden rod the frequency will
increase the closer to the rot you are
so while you're exploring be sure to
take stock of when your controller might
be trying to tell you something but you
don't need to find all of the rot you'll
have to discover at least 65 of them in
order to unlock all of cana's abilities
though kana's spirit pulse is primarily
a tool for solving puzzles lighting up
dark spaces and unlocking collectibles
it has offensive potential too most
notably it causes your bombs to explode
which helps if you don't want to wait
for the bombs to go off on their own or
you want to save your arrows
in most combat scenarios you'll have to
kill all the enemies in order to reveal
the source of the corruption and cleanse
the area you know you're done with
combat when enemies stop spawning
however there are a few moments where
you'll be put into a fight where there
are multiple points of corruption you'll
need to cleanse in these instances one
or two points can usually be cleansed
right from the start and they'll just
keep spawning enemies indefinitely until
you stop them try to get to these points
first and close them as quickly as
possible they usually spawn smaller
enemies that are meant to pester you and
distract you from the larger main threat
so getting rid of them early on will
make the fight so much easier
there is friendly fire in bridge's
spirits so even though that
unfortunately means that kana can damage
herself with her own bombs it also means
that the bigger enemies in the game
especially mini bosses and bosses can
damage and even kill smaller enemies so
if you're having trouble dealing with a
group of enemies try to angle a larger
enemy's attack to strike the smaller
enemies around them
the weak points on enemies mini bosses
and bosses are always marked in yellow
you have to shoot them with your bow as
they require a precise strike usually
that yellow is a crystallized chunk of
amber and shooting them will knock that
crystal off the enemy which transforms
into the gold energy that you or the rot
can collect to fill the courage gauge
and use your rot based abilities there
are a few instances where these weak
points can't be shot at immediately
though later on in the game you'll start
running into foes encased in thick armor
or rock and the only way to reveal their
weak points is to bomb them so if a
tough enemy doesn't seem to have a weak
spot try bombing them that will usually
reveal what you need to hit
[Music]
early on you'll unlock the ability to
have the rot interact with specific
flowers and the environment called
forest tiers transforming the rot into a
mass that can water crops clear
corruption and help solve certain
puzzles but it can be used as a weapon
too in instances where you can use that
ability in combat or use it outside of
combat and bring it to a fight go for it
both the spinning and slamming action
that the rock can do deal a lot of
damage be careful though as any hit
whether to kana or the rot will
immediately cause the rod to scatter so
get in as many hits as you can before
the enemy can touch you
you unlock a whole lot of in-game
currency throughout bridges spirits so
don't feel like you have to be frugal
when it comes to buying hats and masks
for your rot you will be swimming in
currency throughout the game even if you
don't spend a lot of time looking for
secrets and collectibles suspend at your
leisure you'll also earn plenty of carmo
points from killing enemies and doing
things like feeding fruit to the rod or
fixing statues in the environment which
you can then use to unlock new abilities
for kana at a fairly steady rate you
won't earn enough that you can just buy
whatever you want unless you plan on
searching off the beaten path and
completing optional quests you won't
finish the campaign with all of kana's
skills unlocked so if you're not down to
explore you do have to be a bit more
selective there but when it comes to
dressing the rot and cute outfits the
sky is the limit though a majority of
the puzzles in bridge of spirits are
pretty straightforward some both
mandatory and optional aren't in a few
cases the hints to a puzzle solution are
tied to the environment forcing you to
look at the world around kinah in order
to figure out what you need to do next
so if you're struggling on a puzzle look
at your immediate surroundings the clue
for a puzzle will always be right near
it so you won't have to go hunting for
information
hopefully those 13 pieces of advice help
you out how do you all feel about the
game leave your thoughts in the comments
section below be sure to subscribe to
gamespot if you're looking for more cana
bridges spirits content like our video
review and some master spirit difficulty
gameplay and be sure to like this video
if you found any of these tips helpful
or want to see us make more videos like
this for other games
you